[Music]
i'll um have to think of something else
[Music]
here
[Music]
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by
dot com you don't have to be a
freeloader your whole life
the good news is that you can support
this show and the fight by buying some
really cool clothes.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's june which marks louder with
crowder's sixth annual
cultural appropriation month where we
take you
across the globe to learn and appreciate
all the diverse cultures this planet has
to offer
because to appropriate is to appreciate
be our guest this week as we take a trip
to the land of sushi
waifus and animated depravity be sure to
leave your shoes by the door
as we visit the land of the rising sun
japan
[Applause]
that was a wonderful sip from the sencha
green tea
i went i went full uh that was harder
yeah that was good adventure green tea
this is our first time back on youtube
cultural appropriation month
hey we're going to be taking uh later on
mug club your pictures and checks
yeah and we have winners we've been
doing this for six years now six years
six years our first show back on youtube
people were saying oh wait
are they going to come back with
cultural appropriation month yes
that's a yeah so uh look before we get
into anything i don't know if it's just
my headphones i'm hearing a little echo
it's probably because it's going through
i think it's 16 layers of fur yeah
the faux leather look i appreciate
everyone uh here everyone who's
watching uh on youtube we're still on
youtube right quarter black oh it's
still up
yeah yeah that's still up breathe in the
head but a lot of you don't know
we've still been doing this show every
day for two weeks
so we haven't been able to stream on
youtube but we have been
and this is just why before we get into
anything else look
i don't know what's going to happen
going forward we don't have all of our
answers from youtube i don't want to
lose contact with you i don't want to
lose a show on youtube i don't want none
of us here want to be a martyr we want
to do a show
and hundreds of millions have changed my
mind videos being removed because
someone in silicon valley gets offended
yeah which could be anything
so just don't let us lose touch with you
okay there are three ways
that you can still watch anytime there's
a break or if that happens in the future
of course mug club
is the best place where you guys can go
right it's uh
even if you watch on youtube mug club is
another 30 to an hour really 45 minutes
to an hour every single day
they get access to the whole blaze
catalog 99 a year 69 for students
veterans active military
you get this wonderful hand-etched green
tea vessel
also but i know that not all of you can
afford mug club you know 99 69
or whatever that averages out to right
seven to ten dollars a month
so uh of course there's the audio
podcast we're available on
apple android spotify you don't see the
video there but
we haven't been removed or censored
there at all they're more lenient with
non-hate speech
and uh also we're really excited rumble
right so you can watch this show
everything that's free on youtube will
still be free
even if it's not on youtube you're not a
member of mug club go to rumble
yeah and right now it's being uploaded
because we can't live stream there in
archive but
we're being told from rumble that uh
that'll be available in the next couple
of weeks
and i don't know them personally seem
like good guys we have been
we've been assured that we will not be
censored we won't be throttled look
i think it's important for us to be on
all of these big tech platforms
because people complain about an echo
chamber and then they continue to create
an echo chamber right that's not what we
want but
yeah i also hear a lot of conservatives
a lot of you out there saying we need an
alternative well we have a paid
alternative with mud club
and now there's rumble and i'd like to
see at least as many of you guys
tuning in watching on rumble to support
them if you're going to give your
dollars to some place
rumble is at least trying to do it right
and just please do not let us lose touch
with you yeah absolutely a lot of people
are asking where to find us when youtube
was banning us
and that is the place make sure even if
you don't watch us on rumble watch us on
youtube and if something happens you
have a backup you're ready to go join
mug club that's a great option and look
youtube it does not have to be this way
we don't want
it to be this one come on man i
understand we we've been reprimanded for
laughing yes when a transgender
individual threw a homeless man's lunch
box at me
that was considered a violation not the
aggravated assault and
well first off the felony theft in
stealing a homeless man's lunchbox
right yeah and then throwing it out yeah
these are the kinds of
of infractions that we've experienced we
don't know
what all these strikes are so it's
stressful we're back we're here with you
and uh hopefully we're here for many
years to come but if not don't
let us lose touch with you okay we have
a lot to get to today
gerald a is here hi looking tasty how
are you sushi i love it
i i would eat this costume i almost said
something else and then yeah so yeah
you did everything there's no longer
there's no longer land it's just
land mines uh quarter black quarterback
ready to go are you ready to go i'm
ready
very good you've got your
methamphetamine in the system
you're doing a great honor and uh of
course dave landau in which sailor moon
uh character are you
taylor what
[Music]
ahoy ahoy yeah this is wonderful i got
to be honest i didn't know we were
dressing up today yeah oh really
he thought it was bring your daughter
slash self to work day yes
he was awesome in the middle of
something apparently dave get to the
studio
okay i don't know if you this about
dresses
but uh you're gonna want to throw this
chair away okay
um we'll flip the cushion oh that's for
sure
yeah flip the cushion i don't know how
that works with these all the way
through the landau seepage so we're
gonna be talking about fouchy today
we have this week in biden we did a
segment on fauci's emails yeah
yesterday but we only had so much time
right because we were doing
the program in the morning there's a lot
more to it and again i have talked about
this before you guys comment
let me know by the way the best thing
you can do here on youtube right now is
share this
right now so that as it's streaming live
you don't miss it
you hit that uh hit the share button hit
the like button
and anything we're talking about today
we will be discussing with you you can
hit the comments just comment comment
comment you don't see me doing this like
a lot of people like hey guys what did
you think comment below it actually ends
up being a conversation but right now we
have to make sure that the algorithms
work because
we need to ensure that in the future for
us they continue to not work
um interactions up so uh
it is time we're gonna be talking about
fouchy i think it's the biggest scandal
yeah of our lifetime
huge i think it's watergate was
basically bugging someone's phone
yeah that's effectively what it boils
down to they do that to american
citizens
every day and forrest gump found it yes
forrest gump found it after he had to
pee from dr pepper
i don't know if it's historically
accurate zemeckis is a problem
[Laughter]
but the point here is um you gotta have
the facts to back up
i don't even know what i was talking
about oh it's the big i do think it's
the biggest scandal
i really do because this is the only
it's not a conspiracy
when you look through the emails and you
look at the public policy and you look
at the policy of facebook youtube
twitter
it all lines up to the letter that they
were
working the term colluding doesn't
necessarily mean something nefarious
yeah in this case it's just accurate
look you had emails being exchanged
between zuckerberg and fauci
international uh virologists and fauci
you had him saying one thing on air
and discussing something else in email
so we're going to put it together to you
not only the emails you probably read
those but a timeline that shows you
exactly what he was saying publicly
while these emails were going on that's
what matters because what he told you
he didn't necessarily believe yeah i'm
not i'm not a tributing motive
i'm reading motive so before we get to
that though it is a
cultural appropriation month because too
appropriate
so some quick japan facts japan i don't
know if you know this has more than 50
000 centenarians
uh with the island of okinawa where
tokunawan's ancestors are from
containing the highest concentration of
centenarians in the world really yeah
well what is
that and they have people over 100 years
old and they smoke cigarettes
centric they do yeah cincinnati
centenary it's a big word sorry
yeah and there was i think the oldest
man in the world for a while was uh
there
in okinawa he was 112. and then he uh
you know
he suicided but people uh people people
suspected
his very competitive uh 111 year old
best friend
that's true um historians in the back
great shame
historians historians and scholars uh
say that kamikaze is actually this is
something we know about kamikaze right
right but we've been taught that they
killed themselves
uh on purpose turns out they were just
really bad pilots yeah didn't know
that i don't teach in the textbooks
where's the 1619 for that
truth uh in the film this is something
that's really you like this in the film
mr baseball tom selleck of course you
know as an american league baseball
player who gets traded to a japanese
team
the team ends up living on the streets
this is what happens people don't know
this in the original version because uh
he traded their houses for reverse
mortgages so there you go
really sad ending it's a really sad
ending hey
this is not my first rodeo
they trust him the whole movie they
trust him way too many and then
all the way to the end nothing they're
left with nothing except all i have is
this a cd-rom that says
my homo belong to government picture of
mr baseball on it
she said this was for my own benefit is
that the big avocado for my money
did you know that tom selleck got caught
stealing water for his avocado farm did
he really when there was a drought in
california
that makes me love him and doesn't even
like avocados he doesn't even like how
he titled me which i love
what it means man he just did it to poke
his finger in their chest like run the
manual in the shower but
uh he uh he he does the reverse
mortgages so you give it you know
the good tom selleck giveth and taketh
away that does suck a little bit
yeah so all right uh here this is
something we need to talk about uh
yesterday former vice president joe
biden
announced a new plan to start
vaccinating uh at uh
at black owned barber shops oh really i
love how whenever joe biden starts
talking
um it's kind of like steven seagal where
one decade he's black one decade he's
italian like you know
which series or films joe biden's been
watching
yeah he's clearly on barbershop too
um but then he really struck his cube so
he gave me that and then he really
struggled to remember how many off
how many months he'd been in office so
this brings us to this week in biden
wait if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump and you
ain't black
in the spirit of meeting people where
they are
we'll also be working with a black
coalition against covet
and other organizations to launch a new
initiative called
shots at the shop barber shops
beauty shops our hubs of activity
information in black and brown
communities particular but in many
communities across the nation
local barbers stylists they become
key advocates for vaccinations in their
communities
since january 20 and we're talking now
about 15 months ago the average daily
cases are down from 184
000. if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump and you
ain't black
bro remember when we thought dan quayle
was silly oh wow
we're gonna have an ice cream truck with
a guy named big worm yeah and he's gonna
be giving out
shots yeah yeah to people who's smoking
dope they like dope and we're going to
be selling new
nikes with you know with the vaccine the
vial in there
nos he's going to sell him yeah he's
literally he started it
uh 18 years ago so it went back when i
was uh you know
president what are you talking about the
fact that nobody even discusses how this
man has completely lost it it's sad
right no one's looking out from they
should be they're family members
absolutely not you know i always trust
my stylist for medical advice
yes that's the person that i tend to go
to yeah hey should i get this vaccine
today well i'm glad you asked yeah i
also call a barber a stylist so you're
not my friend yeah exactly
out of the barbershop i don't think he
realizes how much that would offend
actual
barbers oh it would you would admit
immediately you'd be like oh give me a
number four and take two inches off the
top like
all right i got you thanks you're a
great stylist number one
i thought you said reverse skunk though
yeah i'm gonna make you look like the
skinhead you actually are apparently oh
come on you know the thing um
go to shop with queen latifah's vaccine
she drove she made it uh she was started
with nothing as a taxi driver
in the moving taxi driver jimmy fallon
yes
he struggled you know the brown stylist
oh you know the you know the thing so um
this is one thing
i want to discuss really quickly um the
the violations that we were told here on
youtube before we move on to fouchy
we didn't really get clear answers so
you guys know about the one with
where we praise the cop for defending a
life with makai bryant yeah but the
other ones um we were told that we went
from what i understand it wasn't
specific against either world health
organization guidelines or the cdc
right um and i want to admit fault with
something
uh and this is just me being totally
transparent we issue retractions we
issue corrections i feel like i have to
do this before we move on with the show
i did i did go against the cdc
precisely twice okay now you can you can
determine if you think that's
permissible
uh if you think critical thinking is
allowed if you think criticism is
allowed
or if you think these need to be banned
for misinformation so i'll tell you the
exact
two instances where i went against the
cdc um one was
early on in the pandemic when fauci and
the cdc were saying
don't wear masks they don't do anything
we actually showed you on this show
how to create a mask at home along with
actually a friend's company jocko
willink origin maine
and we said masks don't necessarily help
you from inhaling the virus but it may
prevent others from becoming sick so at
the point when the cdc said
no masks they're more dangerous than not
wearing masks i did go against their
guidelines and say
in some cases masks can be appropriate
in a limited capacity and here's a tail
of the tape back then
you know what else people are saying
well don't try and make masks at home
right
with t-shirts or with whatever fabrics
you have there's that's not going to
work
except they look up looked online and
said well i don't know maybe there is a
way to make a mask at home but i
searched
how to make an at-home mask that might
at the very least be passable provide
some benefit
and the study came back saying that
actually a t-shirt
uh multi uh pl uh multi uh blend like
poly
cotton blend i guess helps and it was
more effective than a plain cotton
t-shirt
or an antimicrobial pillow were about 70
something percent effective
at filtration and almost entirely
effective at blocking droplets
so learning how to do the ninja but
guess where i found that
the cdc you're fda i was looking these
were the guidelines that conducted these
studies
and that's no no don't wear a mask
because at the time it wasn't about
whether they work it was about shortages
for health care workers
yeah so keep in mind during that moment
yeah we said ah maybe masks can help
now i don't know how i got it right and
fouchy got it wrong but again this is
what matters
when you say number two where did i go
against the cdc really the world health
organization which is impermissible it's
policy
yeah um i did suggest last
year early on that uh the virus could
have leaked from a lab
and that was borderline and that was
demonetized in flight two so there are
precisely two times
so i want to be clear when people talk
about censorship they want to think that
they want to tell you that it's all
about pizzagate and
sandy hook hoaxes no no no no look we
were punished
for saying things like actually
sometimes masks fauci said no masks ever
i said well
maybe sometimes never no masks nothing
nothing and then he said came from
nature we said yeah isn't it possible
that maybe it came from a lab
nothing nope no possibility that's the
reason
that this show has been removed and has
been targeted so
that's why i say it's not really about
us it's about all of you
out there it's about everyone out there
they don't want your views here on the
and we're about to um what's up is that
uh
is that the is it got what is it the
godzilla alarm i think it is yeah
hi steven as you can hear the godzilla
alarm is going off
and we have a situation if you'll follow
me
i'll give you a few tips on what to do
so here's what you want to do shoe
godzilla
shoe
oh wow i don't know how they i don't
know how they
they live under the thumb i i don't i've
got you you've never seen the movie
he's a he's not a hero you might say
you've never seen a good
godzilla excuse me matthew
matthew broderick was the worst that's a
lot of fun you know matthew broder
because
that film is actually when i learned
what bad writing was before yeah before
i move on this is a true story
i remember this so i've told this story
before anyone remember you guys you can
just comment do you remember the
godzilla film with matthew broderick
hank azaria um remember when they're
caught in like i think it was a train or
a bus
yeah and they're in the car and
godzilla's trying to eat them and uh
they're stuck
right it's over right but then matthew
broderick has an idea not not cheating
on sarah jessica parker he has an idea
and uh not that now he turns he's not
behind the wheel of a car
no yeah that's also a bad idea and he
says uh i think i have an idea
and he turns and goes this thing have
high beams and they turn on the high
beams on the on the car and godzilla you
know
this prehistoric monsters look ah it's
bright
and they escaped and i turned to my dad
and i said
what are high beams he said high beams
it's just like a brighter light like you
use dark at dark knight i'm like oh okay
so some cars he goes all cars have them
i go well then why would he need to ask
because that's lazy writing they all
have them yes
of course it is and then i realized oh
they were looking for a one-liner yeah
they couldn't hire a writer who could
create a one-liner so
this thing have high beams like all
moving vehicles
they also sat around like how are we
gonna beat this monster it's like i
don't notice the car brights
bright lights all right so guys on the
scene they're stuck in a train
godzilla's about to eat them how did
they get away yeah that would have
changed the whole film effect of being
like
what's going on that japanese guy down
by the wharf going
just
okay by the way what are they doing
right now okay they're
they're talking about shootings on cnn
lovely that's always maggie
but you know what they were talking
about earlier the number of people on
cnn
not the fouchy emails we'll get to in a
second they actually uh and this is how
fake news starts
how it happens i was in the shower and i
always listen to cnn when i'm getting
ready for how much time in the morning
[Laughter]
mandatory costume though let's make sure
it has to be all portions of the costume
you can't just put on the wig don't be
lazy with it no no i go all out
so um and i heard them saying
and i thought hmm they're saying this i
had not heard this but maybe there was
something that i missed
yeah they said that donald trump was
egging on followers saying that he could
be reinstated right that was his
in august let me show you the clip this
was this morning
on cnn new york times maggie haberman
writes quote trump has been telling a
number of people he's in contact with
that he expects he'll get reinstated by
august
new york times reporter maggie haberman
joins us now she's a washington
correspondent all the time to the cnn
political analyst
maggie i have to say when you wrote that
my eyes popped i i was stunned really
the president is telling people he
expects to be reinstated by august
what's going on
what's your source ink on my finger what
he's doing is echoing
things that are being said by sidney
powell who was his lawyer although
you know she he distanced himself from
her at certain points
over the final months of the
administration but she was helping
advise him
on these efforts to overturn the
election last year let it never be said
that social distancing holds no value
you want a yardstick visual distance
here's the thing here
i thought okay donald trump maybe shot
from the hip donald trump maybe said
something no no
nothing there's no basis for it look if
you look at that thing on cnn if you i
don't know if we could even bring it up
uh she tweeted it she tweeted it oh
they they actually don't have any
sources mentioned any sources list
no screenshots at all you can bring i
don't know if we can bring it up as a
freeze frame or anything no screenshots
of any possible trump press statements i
looked for them
now if i'm wrong you guys correct me and
not even according to
anonymous sources at it it's just that
broad in the in the polka dots yeah and
who tweeted it though
that girl or the one that looks like
indiana jones ugly wife
yes no yes the junk muppet lady from uh
labyrinth okay just wanna just said
donald trump clairvoyant you need your
back
that's who tweeted it it's a smorgasbord
of nonsense looking people
it really is this is how journalism
works now you say that people that
donald trump knows he said something to
them i tweeted it and therefore tweet it
out that's the quote literally i looked
at every different news source that i
could find even local news stations that
were covering this
everyone quoted her tweet and that was
it yeah and by the way they asked the
question
the the podesta email leak in twenty
thousand uh twenty thousand sixteen why
am i saying the whole
whoa
uh in 2016 the podesta emails and you
know the wikileaks
they show that haberman was a clinton
political operative oh so you can go we
have again helps all of the sources are
available at lidarwithcredit.com
everything we talk about
if you don't like the sources leave a
comment tell us that we're wrong we make
them publicly available to you
another reason that youtube can't stand
us um
and cnn they don't like that we have
sources yeah no no
so this is just this is a perfect
example right we get a strike yeah and i
don't want to make but you guys
all kinds of people out there get
strikes facebook youtube twitter removed
anyone who said um might be a wuhan lab
leak
right might be a leak from a lab removed
cnn who
by the way are considered authoritative
sources by
big tech platform politico washington
post snopes
they're included there's no
accountability there do you think
hey can someone search we'll bring this
up later can someone search to
washington post snopes politifact
how many pinocchios did that get it's
not going to get any come on washington
posted what 50 thousand from donald
trump
for things like where he said my pool is
uh uh twenty five feet long it's
actually twenty four point eight they
did all of these fact checks
right that is an entirely fabricated
story
we can verify it guarantee that clip
won't count as a strike against cnn
and you'll wonder why people think there
are rules for the elites
and there are rules for you i'm telling
you that's how it works
and it's not just government the biggest
concern right now is big tech
in bed with government that is shameful
yeah and maggie's
basically what she's pushing out there
he said okay well it's dangerous enough
on its own
but what cnn and everybody else is doing
is saying thank god trump is not on
twitter or facebook because this is a
call to violence
right this is a call that led to the
same situation we had on january 6th
right thank god they're getting him off
this like
the the very first question that you ask
when it's an unnamed source
is this a source close to the president
is this somebody right inner circle like
don't you try to drill down knowing you
won't get a name necessarily because
it's anonymous but you're like i want to
make this as solid as possible
no questions just as silly as q anon
we're like someone who they believe is
close to the president
well you just quoted someone who we know
was close to the runner-up president
yeah
and you even had to say this all came
from uh sidney powell right
sydney powell is echoing this and that's
probably where donald trump got it and
she had to say
yes he distanced himself from her but
they're they've got to still be close
right yeah i got misgendered on the
airplane
it happens i told you you're not allowed
to take the outfit from the studio
that's a business experience
you should see the dry cleaning bills oh
geez all right so also uh
the covered pandemic by the way has
really disrupted the fast food industry
not only here but in japan
as we know now automation we talked
about this yesterday the american dream
it's actually americans
also not working which is sort of
forcing automation not the other way
around
um but now in japan this is a trend that
a lot of people don't know cultural
differences
you know used panty vending machines
have popped up
all over the country yeah it's a thing
that actually happens in uh in japan i
own many
and uh we actually i think we machine we
got one here in the office right
oh no not exactly it's it's kind of more
of a like a
deposit so we the the panning vending
machine
it no it's it's more of like a
receptacle of sorts you put panties in
the vending machine yeah that's not the
same at all
[Music]
[ __ ]
well if we had an hr department that
would be a violation yeah well
let me go on that look i have no idea
tokunawan token island by the way the
actual guy was
a quarter japanese look at that outfit
there you is that a fan
in it right yeah that's it it looks like
it looks like e honda can you give us
give us the e honda
give us the e honda hand slap
people listening on audio have no idea
how funny it is
like they put a geisha on top of them to
breed right isn't that
for real on top of what a sumo like a
sumo lays there and they're like they
put a geisha on it's not a panda
i don't think that's how it works is it
not true
i think there's probably some truth to
it dave i'm pretty sure
the pretty rose get their pick of the
litter because they're considered
uh certainly part of the upper class
that's what i mean but you don't want a
sumo on
top of a geisha no you're right yeah
probably
you'll figure that out yeah or and i
don't know where panda came from but
i'm down dave's like i'll try anything
pandas shouldn't exist what do you know
know what bears have for breakfast panda
cakes they have panda cakes
yes you have a son that's a dad joke yes
shouldn't exist
if human beings need to teach you how to
screw
you've been selected natural selection
says
you have no look look yeah it's not like
okay they didn't adapt to
modern economies it's not like
deforestation right
it's the fun part of biological
evolution
but they're ying and yang
all right so let's get into the fouchy
emails here you guys have all read read
about this right and dave you've been
reading these emails yes
yes yeah they're all quite alarming it's
it's a lot it's a lot to absorb and we
did a short version yesterday but
there's there's more to a lot of people
just think it's about him
uh you know being dishonest about masks
we'll get to that but there's more than
that here look the biggest controversies
here
have been what that uh okay it was there
any information that was a wuhan
lab leak right could this have been
engineered all of these were denied of
course by fouchy
what happened with the masks did he have
some information there and then of
course a lot of people tried to accuse
uh donald trump of muzzling fought these
were the big controversies
right that donald trump was anti-science
we know beyond any shadow of a doubt
that none of those are true and it's
worse than that so
first okay uh let's let's start this off
with the man of the hour who's been
right about
everything rand paul every time they've
gone tit for tat
you just wait two weeks and you put one
on the scoreboard for senator rand paul
as [ __ ] as he can be
he still was right here we go the emails
paint a disturbing picture
a disturbing picture of dr fauci from
the very beginning
worrying that he had been funding gain
of function research
and he knows it to this day but hasn't
admitted but really there's a lot of
evidence that he has a great deal of
conflict of interest
and that if it turns out this virus came
from the wuhan lab which it looks like
it did
that there's a great deal of culpability
in that he was a big supporter of the
funding
but he also was a big supporter to this
day of saying we can trust the chinese
on this
we can trust the chinese scientists and
i think that's quite naive and
really should preclude him from the
position that he's in two weeks ago in
committee hearing he said they did not
fund
any gain of function research i quoted
that specific paper
right so the very paper that he puts in
the email he says
oh my goodness we need to read this
paper because we looks like we are
actually funding gain of function
research
which is where we juice up these viruses
take them from animals and infect them
into humans
he's admitting that to his underlying
he's worried about this
in february of last year could there be
criminal culpability here a fraud or
ongoing collaboration with the chinese
when when he was
making excuses for them at the very
least there's moral culpability
now two things it's always funny when
you have a side by side of rand paul and
fauci because you have one guy who
deserves to be swirlied and one guy who
looks like a toilet brush
yeah it's true they work together
faucious looks like a virus wearing a
person costume yes
that's exactly like you take you take it
off and it'll just be those characters
in dr mario yes
exactly there's something just throw
more pharmaceuticals at it
that are a part of the company on which
i sit on the board
so uh look here's this this is something
important uh and
and also the other thing that i said two
things i don't know that you can accuse
fouchy of perjury i don't know if you
can accuse him of
because he's taken two sides on every
issue right i understand that science is
developing
here's the it's a developing process
here's the issue he would say
science is settled and then policy was
made and then he would pull a 180.
that's not the same as saying hey we're
in the process right of testing a
hypothesis
so let's be cautious no no you said it's
settled
it's natural social distancing lockdowns
and we devastated the economy then said
oh maybe it doesn't work that's very
different
don't hide behind science and by the way
it must be a very short science block
i don't think i i am i wouldn't be
surprised if we do some digging
and he got some of that [ __ ] money in
college if you're under five feet
you get [ __ ] money i know this because
i knew a [ __ ] who was living high on
the hog while all my friends were
struggling with debt oh my gosh you're
telling me i could have had
freak tape well that you are actually
the most unfortunate because
just barely you miss it yeah oh man oh
they laugh at me well look they laugh at
you and you don't get you don't get
they don't get the uncle sam dollars the
only time i'm too tall
in your life well like it's not only
that that what fauci said with flipping
and going back and forth is that people
lost their livelihoods because they
disagreed with them right and
knew that those things that we've talked
about and we'll get into details on each
that they were possible that they were
still in process the investigations
weren't
going so let's stand up and say let's
get to these clips so let's let me show
you what dr
fauci was saying and i use that term
loosely doctor usually a doctor should
see a patient
at least once or we should know where he
came from not just
a pier a year and a half ago yeah and
ruin everyone's life he just came
out of the water and the man at the
wharf said godzilla
high beams and no work oh
[Music]
only men are dumber than the script for
godzilla
also he was a godzilla scripted
consultant so oh you know you know
bring a great shame full circle so
um on may 5th
he was talking about you know people
were questioning is there a possibility
that this is man-made is that public
publicly he was saying no here you go do
you believe or is there evidence that
sars kobe 2 was made in the lab in china
or accidentally released from a lab
in china well you know there's two
issues
if you look at the evolution of the
virus in
bats and what's out there now
it's very very strongly leaning towards
this
could not have been artificially or
deliberately
manipulated the way the mutations have
naturally evolved
a number of very qualified evolutionary
biologists
have said that everything about the
stepwise evolution over time
strongly indicates that it evolved in
nature and then
jumped species now i'm not saying that
that is not true but you said
not possible at that point he kind of
couched his words but at one point he
said
not possible i think he catches every
word he does like it kind of may be
possible and that's a problem because a
doctor
shouldn't effectively be running for
office i think he's the highest paid
person in the federal government i think
it's 800 000. that's what he makes only
twice what the president makes
and you know listen he uh we i'm not
saying that he has to be perfect
said 20 million americans would be dead
by 92 from aids big swing and a miss but
at least he swung the bat
in a bath house do you do some research
on some really messed up this isn't new
i knew everything that i need to know
about him
looking back to the aids pandemic this
guy is
um i don't want i don't know if i'm not
allowed to question authoritative
sources if we just call him a dick is
that okay
questioning a dick like fauci well if he
wasn't a bath house in the 80s
yeah that's fine that was really he just
wanted funding
for his own medical issues i'm telling
you everyone's going to have aids
could it couldn't be that you uh spent
uh nine days in a row in a russian bath
house without coming up for air
no it's going to affect everyone
including monogamous heterosexual
couples
i don't know how this happened
it just makes common sense of course
thank you very much
all right so that was in may yeah
january 31st 2020 now we go to the
emails
fauci forwarded a science magazine
article titled mining coronavirus
genomes for clues to the outbreak
origins
to immunologists kristin anderson and
british medical researcher jeremy farrar
fauci wrote this just came out today you
may have seen it
if not it is of interest to the current
discussion this is about it potentially
being manipulated
right the reply from anderson to fauci
read
and i want to be really clear here this
was a reply to him so fauci said hey
this came out
seems like it's a concern he just said
many qualified virologists
and evolutionary biologists say it came
from nature
again that's the lie by omission because
there were many many many many many
medical experts who said that's not
likely but guess what they all got
banned
and we'll get to the policy of big tech
in a second this is what was sent back
to fauci
from a qualified virologist or
immunologist or bio i don't know
on a phylogenetic on a phylogenetic tree
the virus looks totally normal
and the close clustering with bats
suggests that bats serve as the
reservoir
the unusual features of the virus make
up a really small part of the genome
about 0.1 percent so one has to look
really closely at all the sequences
to see that some of the features
potentially look
engineered we have a good team lined up
to look very critically at this
so we should know more by the end of the
weekend now should be clear
he's since defended his co his comments
and he said that uh the analysis said
the virus was not man-made
that would seem like oh open and shut if
it was the only example that we had
yeah absolutely but it's not and it's an
ongoing process right he said that you
had to look really closely to see some
of those things looked engineered i'm
like okay were you able to work
in in china and actually get all of the
data to make sure
right did you did you address the theory
of a bats a thousand miles away that
were in hibernation
did you go through all these processes
and definitively rule it out
no you never made that comment what you
did is you had fauci coming out and
saying
it looks most likely like this and they
use that to be keep in mind
and this is why we're not going to live
in a in a culture of self-censorship of
fear anymore
we were warned okay and so we weren't
allowed to talk about this back then
but facebook youtube and twitter have
changed their official policy
where it's no longer a conspiracy we're
allowed to have these discussions
now if we had this discussion three
months ago hard strike
or a ban and i i gotta tell you i need
some new conspiracy theories
i don't have any left it's getting
difficult they're just
facts well i think it's best to try to
prove the facts once it's too late yes
exactly
after it could save lives yes it's very
important and after you've banned
everybody for sure so
that's in that video he's just wearing
like a don mob dawn suit
got a golden blockbuster logo behind him
he's just stuck in a werther's original
you notice he's always got something in
his mouth i think it's werther's yeah i
think it's like
he wants it all for him i hate these
like m
m's all for me none for you it's just a
zinc vitamin d
you get nothing yeah and uh by the way
let's i've talked about this again i
haven't been on youtube but i think let
me ask you this and you guys can comment
i'm gonna move on down the list here
with a whole lot of crap that many of
you may not know we've gone through all
of the emails
if this virus if we knew what we know
now about this virus that it potentially
leaked from a lab
and again i'm willing to bet my bottom
dollar that it does why
because it was already a one issue it
would be like if tomorrow
all of a sudden the media said well
maybe there was some kind of election
issue you go wait hold on a second
you said nothing you said there was no
there were no election shenanigans
and you removed anyone who talked about
it why are you addressing it now
it's because they have to get out in
front of something so
donald trump launched an investigation
he said leaked from a lab
joe biden said that was racist fauci
said no way we had an election
and now we're saying seems more likely
than not or at least as likely that it
leaked from a lab
do you think that if americans knew that
that changes the election
let me let me offer you this i think
it's the difference
in a narrative going into the election
disregarding the hunter biden story
which would have caused
12 percent of blind voters to switch
their vote it's a narrative that
switches from donald trump has handled
the pandemic
to a declaration of war from china
effectively
who do you think yeah you think that
might have affected the american
people's
vision considering that donald trump was
saying don't trust china biden saying
china all is good same thing with fauci
so again he said he trusted china here's
another
email february 1st again before that
video that you saw fauci emailed the
same article
sorry go ahead no the other side of that
coin though could be that you know
people were worried that it was because
of trump that china had that
you know wanted to come after us let's
just say that i don't think it was
deliberate i think it was an accident
no but i'm saying if there's any
potential whatsoever it could have also
changed where it does change the
election even more in biden's favor
so why the uh cover-up well
i don't think it would because again
donald trump was just he wasn't saying
this was deliberate he's saying look
this is a leak and now they're trying to
cover it up i'm just trying to stay on
the channel
no well look i don't believe what i said
either
oh they do see him
because i'm trying to figure out what an
idiot would say yeah
and clearly look at me you have to think
about it look
i i think at the very least it wasn't
racist
and that's what they claimed xenophobic
and racist
yeah donald trump couldn't even say this
and most of them says the guy dressed as
sushi
very seriously most important of all
wasn't racist yeah and saying kung flu
wuflu
from a sitting president was incredibly
funny yeah and it was pushed back come
on it was push me i've
never been prouder of my country than to
see a sitting president
make puns at another nation's expenses
he's like the kung flu he's waiting for
a gun
all right we'll work on it we'll get
that element next time
so
[Applause]
you know joe biden hears a gun anytime
he hears a gong he assumes he lost
something like that
all right i guess the other guy got it
so uh february 1st 2020 fauci emailed
the same article
mining coronavinus genomes for clues to
the outbreak's origins to principal
deputy director
at the national institute of allergies
and infectious diseases um
the guy named alken klaus i don't know
he replied all the sources of
crowd.com he replied the paper you sent
me says the experiments were performed
before the gain of function
pause but have since been reviewed and
approved by nih
not sure what that means since emily is
sure that no coronavirus work has gone
through the p3 framework
she will try to determine if we have any
distant ties
to this work abroad to which fauci
applied okay stay tuned but um we
weren't tuned
i guess it wasn't the same fouchy time
or channel yeah different channel
apparently
i'm sorry so gain a function pause yeah
doesn't something have to be ongoing to
be paused
you would think yeah even even my 97
year old grandmother-in-law with the big
blue pause button on her vcr she's
figured it out
jose yeah yeah right well and it also
isn't a a
gain of function stop right it is a gain
of function pause which means
there is a possibility that they would
restart it i mean did can fauci
lie any further here's here's something
to i we don't know that he knew
gain of function okay but we do know
that money from the united states went
to this institute which of course
conducted very likely
gain of function research it's like
saying money that goes to planned
parenthood doesn't go to abortion it
goes
they don't do breasts they don't have
mammogram machines they've never had a
mammogram machine
right and behind the scenes fauci was
already
very concerned that gain of function had
gone on
yeah that's very different from what he
told the media saying no you have it
absolutely completely
incorrect well good enough for me sounds
like donald trump's going to attempt a
coup in august who told you
i don't know madeleine albright they
don't care
oh by the way oh we have to check let's
check in with cnn uh they have uh
okay no it's another commercial break
yeah we can just uh
continue is it is it it's catchy
is it a commercial systems
[Music]
sensei level four body armor
to get to highest quality american meter
body armor and save 10 percenter
use a promo code crowder
i don't you know the thing is i'm just
the only thing that bothers me is uh he
was dressed like a ninja turtle from the
third movie in china
i love her hair yeah yeah well you wear
it she's good
who wore it better of course she did i
love our sponsors
this is why we do so few uh so few ads
because most sponsors
would just read the outline no no yeah
no we're gonna go sell uh uh nature box
on uh
on uh h3 yeah you gotta have balls too
by the way let me just get this so uh
some of the ten by three
dollars for a box or raisins some of the
10x12 plates out there they actually
only protect like an eight by ten area
uh the spartan hercules they're level is
it level three or is it level four
level four plates actually protects the
full 10 by 12. it's curved
it really is the most comfortable plate
out there and it has whatever the
coating is so that you don't get the
fragments i
look pretty awesome we've shot it at the
range we wanted to shoot me here in the
studio i was told that we didn't have
enough liability insurance
as a matter of fact we had it lined up
and i was about to do it until half
asian bill basically
no yeah storming into the studio stop
so i stabbed axed and sorted yes you
were
but it was by it was by uh our weak
asian intern so come on
let's not complain uh smartnumbers.com
use a coupon code
crowder you get 10 off great american
company they support the show
yes um we appreciate it we don't need
the japanese game show thing that's fine
okay uh okay let's go to uh fauci uh
okay this is another thing that people
are talking about that he
claimed uh masks were effective publicly
at blocking even larger covid particles
he made the claim that masks work okay
this is something he did
we usually say well you know regular uh
particles
that are from you know uh scrotum
they're greater than five micrometers
they tend to fall to the ground
right within six feet then we find out
from the aerosol
particle of scholars that say you know
there are there are larger particles
than that that stay floating
around a lot longer so you shouldn't
assume they all go to the ground which
adds weight
to the role of aerosolization is
something that will save
adding weight this is something we need
to re-examine
so i'm trying to get some of those
people to talk a little bit more to us
about it the one thing that it does
tell you it's important is that
you really better wear a mask bro okay
so in february he wrote to american
university president sylvia burwell and
i understand
science changes but he didn't give a
reason as to why his science changed he
gave a very emphatic
explanation against masking that's kind
of but now we think
we think it maybe works for some stuff
so this is what he wrote masks are
really for infected people
to prevent them from spreading infection
to people who are not infected
rather than protecting uninfected people
from acquiring infection
and then she responded fauci you are
such an infection
look what you did you little jerk stop
it uncle frank
[Music]
the typical mask you buy in the
drugstore is not really effective in
keeping out the virus which is small
enough to pass through the material what
it might however provide some slight
benefit
in keeping out gross droplets if someone
coughs or sneezes on you as i am prone
to do
when sitting in the middle seat in coach
i do not recommend
that you wear a mask particularly since
you are going to a very low risk
location he recommended
someone at the pandemic pandemic had
already started who was getting on a
flight
not to wear a mask and in depth
explained why it didn't work why not to
unbelievable that he was writing the the
particles and people said this
people not us but people said this and
we're banned for it
particles will pass through the average
mask that people go to the store and buy
you're
your husband your wife is a nurse
yeah and your wife husband is a doctor
yes
actually she's a saudi prince your wife
was a nurse and she said look the reason
that there's a shortage is because
you can't use the mask more than once
you use it once and then you have to
basically touch it with your hands and
disinfect it take it off throw it out a
disposable mask and we didn't have the
ability
to sanitize the kinds of masks a lot of
hospitals
still don't
[Music]
it's just killing these cheap masks
that's it no more cheap masks no
name that reference i'm just seasoning
it um so here's the thing it changed the
science
why did the science change why did the
science change i don't know but what
kind of an idiot puts the correct thing
in writing and sends it to someone
someone you know what someone who
doesn't fear accountability yeah
yeah i guess someone who doesn't think
that anyone might do some digging and
again
why do we think there was an fy request
from buzzfeed in washington post
people right now are trying to get out
ahead of this they're treating fauci
very differently why
public opinion has turned they want to
make him the fall guy
they wanted to make him the expert
governor whitmer had a hump pillow
in her office mental image and now
we make it now they want to act like we
don't know how we feel about you well
that just changed
very recently and we know why okay so
fauci
claimed that the initial mass guidance
uh changed
because the science changed which would
stand to reason right
but now we have a tail of the tape but
let's go to the clip first so i'm i'm
hoping that you can tell us a bit more
oh my gosh if you were an alien
geneticist and this was the first thing
you saw
just go to your home planet and say we
don't want it for people around the
country to be like oh we've already
colonized
yeah i mean obviously when you're
dealing with with with something that's
changing in real time mark
that's really the nature of science you
you look at
the data and the information you have at
any given time
and you make a decision with regards to
the
course
as the information changes then you have
to be flexible enough
and humble enough to be able to change
how you think about things
and i think you know one of the
important things that we're emphasizing
what are humbles are that really look at
his haircut he's a billionaire
that did change is our insistence now
on wearing masks okay so the truth is
that if you look at the emails
the changing science look fauci said
masks don't work
then he changed his mind from something
directly taken from chinese scientists
who by the way
of course work under the chinese
communist government we know that
they're one and the same
some of them want to flee fauci doesn't
talk about those people the world health
organization doesn't talk about those
people
the people who he only trusts the people
who are under the thumb of the ccp so
march 16th 2020 the email was sent from
michael liu
and uh included advice from dr zhang
director of the infectious disease
department at the
huashon hospital the email said
i strongly suggest american people
should wear masks like
chinese south korean people etc because
even china's highest leader mr xinping
wear mask to which fauci replied
thank you for your note we indeed have
learned much from our chinese colleagues
i appreciate you bringing these issues
to our attention look we have learned
some things from our chinese colleagues
okay
fireworks noodles thank you not in how
to deal with pandemics or medical ethics
well no i would like to ask a very
specific question and this really pisses
me off because he said oh the science
has changed you have to be humble
what changed about the science yeah did
did the virus get smaller
or larger so that mass will catch it did
masks get better at catching viruses
that are too small
what change that made masks effective dr
fauci says that he trusts the chinese
the chinese scientist he says i don't
know much about the chinese government
well they work for the chinese
government
but uh i am willing to take them at
their word
[Music]
sex robot i told you to never come to my
work david i want my money i don't have
your money
don't give me that debt duck i want my
money david you sound like a pimp right
now you're programmed to be a sex slave
do you think what you did to my hard
drive comes free you told me to ram it
plus i owe you money you ruined the
backseat of my buick
you ruined the backseat of your buick
david get out of here i
i'm working go go yeah yeah let's go
oh geez unprofessional a sex robot
see you later oh good lord see you later
all right
[Music]
i've never been more ashamed of our own
cultural appropriation month okay
uh i don't even know him oh now the legs
are crossed
yeah minute ago what you were saying
well i knew that there was a stench i'm
more upset about the use of our budget
that's true that was actually half this
year's budget for making money
nor sex robots row on trees can i tell
you a secret
i don't know if i'm gonna like this the
robot works okay oh jeez look this isn't
bring your sex robot to work day yes it
is
no it's not yes it is it is for him then
again every day every day every day
thank you and then we're compared to
japan hey they don't have as much gun
crime sure but they have massive suicide
and
sex robots so you know what i think we
should go another direction
just my opinion and it's also weird in
japan did you know this if they sleep
with their wife once they've been
married for a long time because it's
considered like a familial relationship
like a sister
what yeah yeah so then they just watch
tentacle pornography my point is
not all cultures are equal okay they
don't share sexually frustrated no they
they they sleep behind different you
know those paper mache walls
yeah yeah what about dick van dyke he
didn't sleep with his lady
yeah but they they just separated the
beds for television you know once
once it went to the security cameras oh
boy
uh so fouchy in april 2020 he denied the
possibility this is another one that the
virus could have come
from a lab which is what we're talking
about now let's go to the clip
there was a study uh recently that we
can make available to you where
a is he an emotive highly qualified
evolutionary virologist platform the
sequence is there
the sequence i've just had him dig a
hole in the stage
i represent the lollipop and
the mutations that it took to get to the
point where it is now
is totally consistent with a jump
of a species from an animal to a human
i'm also a martin short character the
paper will be available
i'm grown clifford is right now but we
can make that available too
uh also i would like to welcome you to
pumpkin land so there you
go i'm standing between two giants
get him an apple box or something that's
not fair for crying out loud give him
the
tom cruise treatment something now what
i love is that you know donald trump
didn't
oh yeah they were like should we give
him should we give him an elevated
platform no
don't even think about it well you know
he can talk as much as he was
down there and you know what he's like
make sure you use the wide shot
yes yeah what lens are you
using i don't know the 24 bigger
i want to be in the schneider picture
i need landscape
do they still use letterbox
[Laughter]
also take away his letterbox
uh so uh the email that fauci sent on
february 22 he sent this to michael
jacobs
talking about this is different from
being engineered yeah could be
engineered this is specifically about it
leaking from a lab so we have evidence
of both
this is what it reads we think that
there is a possibility that the virus
was released from a lab in wuhan
the biotech area of china we also think
the virus might be complex with another
organism such as
a yeast or fungus is it is it talking
about algae
to make it more sticky we would like to
discuss this with you further we feel
that
immediate action must be taken by the
united states
scientists to try and neutralize this
threat but that's not all
on april 19th 2020 he had peter de
vazak i don't know how to pronounce his
name i don't care sources of available
letters with crowder.com you can correct
me
i only pronounce names in american
d sec he thanked fauci which seems weird
again in writing
yeah in writing this what you're about
to hear
is something that if you just said like
at a cocktail party yeah
you know where fauci would be carrying
around the orders
um on his head dress like the planters
peanuts guy penguin just kiss his
forehead
welcome to fantasy item so what's what's
weird is he emailed
him yeah in writing thanking fauci for
dismissing the lab leak theory okay
he's the president of eco-health
alliance to be clear we can bring up
this source
the recipient of 3.7 million dollars
from the national institute of health
grant
uh and uh 600 000 of that went to the
wuhan institute
of virology the zak is also in the team
of leading the investigation
into the who and origins of kovid so
i trust them i trust him and i trust the
chinese i love how who says well we've
investigated them really how'd you run
the investigation did you let the
chinese do it
and what did the chinese say about the
chinese they didn't they didn't do
anything wrong
you're bullshitting well this is kind of
explaining where this guy came from of
nowhere for some
weird reason and he's almost like he
would have the information it's almost
like he had the inside lane that's some
industry talk here crazy
he said to zach to fauci this is what it
reads i just wanted to say a personal
thank you on behalf of our staff
and collaborators is that no sorry yeah
i mispronounced criminals
for publicly standing up and stating
that the scientific evidence supports a
natural origin for coven 19 from a bat
to human spillover
not a lab release from the wuhan
institute of virology from my
perspective your comments are brave and
coming from your trusted voice will help
to smell these myths blah blah to which
fouchy responded
many thanks many thanks for your kind
note
i appreciate that you appreciate the
lies
that is unbelievable like it it matters
where this came from it matters how this
happens
it matters that a conversation can occur
on which one is the most likely theory
we're not saying that it did
it only matters if you say it matters
that's the issue here it only matters if
we say it matters case in point
no mention of the emails at all today on
cnn no as long as i've been watching
what are they talking about right now
met gates they're basically oh that's
what they thought
do you know what they would do to have
emails like this from matt gates in the
sense
i haven't talked about it because we
don't have any evidence i have no idea
it could be a total witch hunt
or the guy could be a sex fiend i don't
know but the point is cnn has no problem
going with the story this morning donald
trump saying there might be a coup in
august no sources whatsoever
they're going to spend an hour probably
45 minutes at least the d block
talking about matt gates just
speculating
this is the problem they say that they
are news news is supposed to present you
with
facts so that you can make your own
decisions opinion is speculating on
those facts
at cnn they label news speculation
on no facts on no facts we provide you
with the facts with our own sources
we really do our best and i let you know
i'm not news
right i have a slant of course i'm
biased and i try to present you
my opinion these facts are available i
encourage you to read all the emails
they don't want to do that they don't
want a light
at cnn they want to operate in the dark
exactly it just seems odd that it would
take over a year to go where do you
think it came from
uh a laboratory that makes viruses or a
bat
at random yeah i don't know hibernation
it didn't take over a year people were
asking this question from oh yeah
oh no i was asking another lesson i know
i know like everybody's asking this
question and it was a legitimate concern
the only reason
that this mattered is because they hated
donald trump that's it yeah of course
look like a bad person
incompetent he did something wrong
killed hundreds of thousands of
americans
racist and now you have to vote him out
of office and to your point about the
emails right now i've read every cnn
story i could find
75 percent of their first story on this
was how fauci was tired and people were
sending him notes of like condolence i'm
sorry you're having to work so hard i
watched msnbc and wanted to bleach my
eyes more than cnn
they said nobody when when you say
something in private and it becomes
public that's really the test of
somebody's character and they said
you have passed the test like no one of
us could of course he's tired
what sugar gliders like him are
nocturnal
that's true but he didn't they're
they're they're praising him for this
stephen yeah all we're doing is pointing
out inconsistencies here
they're praising him saying that his
there's a clip somewhere i don't have it
but someone was saying
i think you passed the test where uh you
know if anyone's emails are released
usually they don't come out with
flying colors but you do he's like thank
you i appreciate it i was quoting that
was the msnbc thing that i saw there's
an
urgent care doctor smoking a marlboro
right now who works harder than faucet
exactly kidding me there's a sex robot
right now smoking a marlborough working
harder than faucet i'm a doctor that
works harder than
yes i'm not even a doctor all right
here's another one and this is where it
all ties again this is why i say this is
the biggest scandal really i can think
of of our lifetime
remember fauci and the media they were
constantly claiming that trump was
muzzling him yeah yes
right they were saying like yeah that he
felt much freer under biden that fouchy
this is the issue donald trump
is anti-science right and he hates
fouchy because he hates the scientists
right again the narrative was
donald trump wants to play down the
pandemic and fouchy wanted to sound the
alarm and he wasn't allowed to
no here's the truth donald trump didn't
want the country to panic
and devastate our economies and donald
trump was in fact
sounding the alarm vocally publicly on
china
and their untoward actions and that it
was likely a leak and officially
behind the scenes in launching an
investigation fauci was saying
all is well nothing to see here but we
need to shut down all of your
livelihoods but let's be really clear
donald trump was sounding an alarm
fauchi said
nothing to see here so let's watch the
montage of poor fouchie being muzzled
the west wing has been muzzling fauci
adding there were conversations about
not letting fauchi talk on tv
they would say he's exaggerating he's
alarmist no
sign yet that the white house is ready
to take the muzzle off of dr foughtcher
when it comes to national
tv interviews he's continuing to do
interviews like the one he did
on facebook uh today in georgetown a
couple of days ago
notice again no sources back then
telling reporters this that he still
feels like he's getting his message out
just not the way he would like you for
so many times you stood up behind the
podium with donald trump standing
behind you that was a different that was
a different feeling i'm sure than it is
today can you talk a little bit about
about how you feel kind of
released from from what you had been
doing for the last year
yeah but you said i was joking about it
i was very serious
i can tell you that's just why i take no
pleasure at all
the guy is being in a situation of
contradicting the president so it was
really something
that you didn't feel that you could
actually say something and there
wouldn't be any repercussions about it
the idea
that you can get up here and talk about
by the way notice how his shoulders are
higher now
they put him on a box and no that's it
let the science speak it is somewhat of
a liberating look at that now
his shoulders in the last one he was
reaching up like he was using ron paul
peel's pocket fisherman
and right here now he's standing up here
like he's a samurai warrior
they gave him a box that's what it is
it's the little things that irritate him
to be clear at the very least he's a
compulsive liar
okay let me show you how many examples
do i have
as clear as day that he was not being
muzzled from fauci himself
three okay he wrote this march 1st 2020
to the press
please stay silent since i have not been
muzzled
i will be on multiple tv shows and was
on fox this am
no one is censoring me march 2nd 2020
fauci also wrote
i have been very explicit in stating
publicly that i have not been censored
or muzzled
i say exactly what i want to say based
on scientific evidence
i have stated this on multiple
television programs the past few days
including at a major press conference
with many many reporters
including several tv cameras that sounds
like donald trump including many many
television reporters the best reporters
with the best
lenses look at the lenses that they look
at what a lens right folks
he says no he ended it with this no
sensor
no muzzle free to speak out also on
march 2nd in another email
this story is not true i
am not being muzzled or censored
okay sex robot i think i made myself
clear earlier i will talk to you
afterwards yes you did no
david it's not that what i
have a virus said you had protection you
better get yourself checked out
wait i don't need to get myself checked
out i'm a human i can't get computer
viruses
i'm going to get it terminated no you're
not getting it terminated
we will raise it together
[Music]
no we're raising it together
okay okay i'm proud of you let's just
please keep it at home
responsibility taken to be a robot life
i don't even know where to begin with
those gender roles
well i have no idea we look behind you
that's the z and zero okay we are into a
new frontier not to come here
it's it's sorry it's event horizon of
weird sex stuff
well not to be confused with sphere
which is basically the same cover
right
no stop it i want to go back to fauci
real quick yeah
now that my sex robot is i don't he
wrote uh
he wrote fox this a.m yeah i bet you a
thousand dollars
because he didn't know what morning to
use i guarantee it
was like uh this uh oh boy which one is
sorrow
a.m let's see let's see what did i do
i ate uh entirely alone in my breakfast
snook
i sobbed into my loofah for 20 minutes
i'll just say
a.m i don't need to get as specific as
military time because
i fear uh displays of force
i put on the kids gangster costume that
they sent me so i could have big
shoulders in my next talk
i meditate while looking at a poster of
the burger king's kids club
because it brings me to a simpler time
where i wasn't as fearful because i
could hide
in the ball pit putting scott
baio's costume on from bugsy
oh my no what was it was it foxy was it
bugsy or was it bonnie and clyde maybe i
have no idea remember the gangster movie
the point is for that start all children
yeah yeah that's true what no i don't
know there's a gangster movie that
starred all kids oh
i remember baby geniuses and uh fauci
couldn't make the cut no no they're
certainly not in that he wouldn't have
made the dog
he did play the little guy in that
little giants though
that's exactly what he did fauci's
responding by the way in those emails to
people
basically saying look are you being
muzzled i know you're being muzzled
if you're being held against your will
and then they went publicly instead of
clearly being muzzled exactly and he was
like he actually got pissed off in one
of those emails he's like all right
stop like for him saying free to speak
no sensor
whatever is him cussing well you know
what this is do you know what this is
you're seeing a common thread here
it's all ego it's all ego because let's
say he was being muzzled and i think he
probably
he probably was less comfortable
speaking publicly with trump because he
had some people hold him accountable
right yeah there are roles when you work
for administration you need to of course
yeah uh and and so i i think that's the
case but i think as a very small man
they're saying
are you being muzzled it's like saying
hey how many are you now
no i'm a big boy i'm not muzzled
i'm an adult i can say whatever i want
and then when he leaves he goes
yeah i'm more powerful than the
president nikki they didn't let me speak
but
now i'm going to give you the real truth
in other words hey you were also wrong
about masks
no the science changed how did you find
it jing ping told me i'd better do it or
he's going to
swirl me in there you know it goes in
the reverse direction i think like
australia
and my hair won't look right i have a dr
fauci hump pillow
because nothing does it like me it's
like a wrestling buddy only it doesn't
stand up to the wear and tear
like me it's best just to let him finish
clark
so um here's and this goes back to big
tests
we have media suspense keep it keep on
keep in mind cnn msnbc these people were
talking about
we used to think that youtube we used to
think that
new media would allow and there was a
moment in time where this was true
it allowed people like us like you to
get past the gatekeepers
because you can go directly to your
audience but now they this wasn't the
case five years ago
our consultants they are on boards we
don't really know who's on these boards
but we know southern poverty law center
we know that with youtube they have
community guidelines advertiser friendly
guidelines and then borderline
yeah and you don't really know who's in
charge of any of them we do know that
cnn is at least on one
politifact is at least on one washington
post so now they control
what is available informationally to 95
of you in america if facebook twitter
youtube decide that you're just not
going to hear a story
you're not going to hear about the lab
leak they decide you're not going to
hear from
president donald trump guess what you're
not going to hear from president donald
trump and then if he starts a blog
they're going to throttle him in the
search on google it's run
by a handful of people and i want to
show you
uh how complicit they were here with dr
fauci
this is also the problem with hero
worship when you look at the people of
big tech
and of course they have to acquiesce to
china right this is why you
look at the censorship of the hong kong
protests this is why you look at the
censorship
of anyone who went against the world
health organization this is a group of
people
they see themselves mark zuckerberg jeff
bezos
uh the people at google jack dorsey they
see themselves
as kings you're a plebe right that's how
they
and so when they say oh wait a medical
pandemic it's not
we want to trust the scientific process
the scientific community who were split
on these theories
it's give unto us a king and so it
wasn't trust science it was
given to us a king fauci and fouchy
didn't know what he believed but it
determined
policy and probably why you may or may
not have been removed from these
platforms let me give you some examples
here on march 5th 2020
zuckerberg emailed fauci thanking him
for his service and offering to help get
the message out here's the email
i wanted to send a note of thanks for
your leadership and everything you're
doing to make our country's response to
this outbreak as effective as possible
i also wanted to share a few ideas of
ways
we could help you get your message out
but i understand you're incredibly busy
so don't feel a need to reply unless
these
seem interesting here's my question and
i'm going to get to the big tech
policies in a second guys let me go with
this
um can we get an foa request did he send
that out to
any of the scientists who were blowing
the whistle hey how about the chinese
scientist was it lee mang
i can't remember the name who left
defected
like moscow on the hudson did they send
that email hey thanks for your bravery
thanks for blowing the whistle we would
really like to help you mark zuckerberg
here susan wojcicki here hey
we'd really like to help you make sure
that you get this information out
because we think it's
important for the public to know it i'd
be willing to bet my bottom dollar no
but they wanted to put fouchy on your
home page who said
don't believe these people who are
actually actually risking life and limb
these chinese scientists who have
decided to go rogue
who have said this is what happened and
by the way half of the scientific
community
with whom i'm communicating behind the
scenes don't trust them
trust what i say and he's got
the leaders of the communist party on
speed dial when you look at this the
leaders of the chinese government
on speed dial because you know the left
hand doesn't know what the right hand is
doing did
zuckerberg dorsey wagetsky did any of
them
reach out to people who were more
qualified
than fauci who were sounding the alarm
we know they banned doctors yeah we know
they banned doctors
we know they banned one of our videos
yeah
for saying that it went against what
what what the world health organization
okay now let's go to zuckerberg behind
the scenes kind of influential guy
emailing vouchers saying hey how can we
work together do you think this may have
something to do
with the policy okay the net result
youtube's policy
youtube doesn't allow content that
spreads medical misinformation that
contradicts local health authorities
or the who's medical information about
covid19
natural man-made taiwan doesn't exist
facebook we remove content that repeats
other false health
information primarily about vaccines
that are widely debunked
by leading health organizations such as
the world health organization
and the cdc hold on a second
what does that mean because now
facebook has just changed their policy
yeah they've just said okay okay okay
we'll allow the lab leak theory i don't
think it was a theory and i don't know
why
you reached it well i know exactly why
but i'm asking you guys comment this is
important to smash that like button
if you're watching right now and god
forbid i don't think we've done anything
here
that should warrant it being removed but
who knows
because some of these emails from fauci
that i've just read go against the
[ __ ] cdc
okay let's be clear yeah some of the
stuff that i've just read contradicts
the guidelines right now and it's from
fouchy so i don't know the context or if
i'm going to be the one left holding the
bag
but facebook said now that theory
is allowed that theory is allowed in our
platform i don't know about youtube if i
made an official announcement
well why was it a theory when half of
the medical community
and the current sitting president had
launched an investigation into it
based on probable cause the only reason
you determined that it wasn't a theory
is because
the chinese communist government said it
wasn't
and fauci agreed and that is a scary
place
this isn't just about conservative
centrist
this is about removing voices from the
table
so that you can't know the truth and
look wherever you line up on covet
lockdowns no lockdowns masks no masks
if you've been vaccinated if you think
four year olds need to be vaccinated i'm
not here to talk about that
i'm just asking you left right center
genderqueer
don't you think that we would all be
better off
if the scientists and the president
sounding the alarms
saying hey this may be coming from a lab
this may be
man-made and by the way there are some
measures that need to be taken
you guys are going in the wrong
direction if they were wrong
how would that hurt a democratic
conversation
how would that hurt a free society
because we now know without any shadow
of a doubt
that it would have helped in the form of
millions of lives saved
and potentially an entirely different
electoral map
so yeah that's what and by the way i am
going to say we're going to play newest
gender pronouns
i have to go uh real quick so i would
say piss off youtube what's that what
what's really weird where is he headed
wait what was that
what's happening